EXCUSE ME. WE ALREADY ARE A
COMMITTEE. BUT A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM. HOW'S
THAT? SO WE'RE GOING TO, START
WITH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
THANK YOU FOR BEING ON TIME.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
1797 SEVEN. MEMBER. PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR AND STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THE BILL, THIS IS AB 1797. SO
METACARCINUS MAGISTER, KNOWN AS
THE DUNGENESS CRAB, IS A
HALLMARK OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST, VITAL TO THE MARINE
ECOSYSTEM AND ECONOMY IN
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM THE
NATIONAL OCEANIC, OCEANIC AND
ATMOSPHERIC ADMINISTRATION. AN
ANNUAL DUNGENESS CRAB LANDINGS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE AVERAGED
ABOUT $57 MILLION A YEAR FOR THE
PAST DECADE, WITH SOME YEARS
REACHING AS HIGH AS 90 MILLION.
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
DUNGENESS CRAB INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA IS MULTIFACETED,
SUPPORTING NOT JUST THE DIRECT
PARTICIPANTS OF FISHERIES, BUT
ALSO A WIDE RANGE OF RELATED
BUSINESSES, INCLUDING
RECREATIONAL CRAB FISHING,
COASTAL RESTAURANTS IN INNS AND
OTHER HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES. AS
PART OF THE ECOSYSTEM, DUNGENESS
CRABS CREATE MICROHABITAT MATS,
PLAY A ROLE AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
INDICATOR AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
BALANCE, PRODUCTIVITY AND
RESILIENCE OF MARINE ECOSYSTEMS.
IN 2021, SB 80, AUTHORED BY
SENATE PRO TEM MCGUIRE AND
COAUTHORED BY THE CHAIR AND
OTHERS, PROMOTED SAFETY,
EXTENDED HARVEST OPPORTUNITIES,
AND THE PRESENCE OF ELEVATED
DOMOIC ACID LEVELS AND ENHANCED
THE DATA COLLECTION NECESSARY TO
SUSTAINABLY MANAGE CRAB
FISHERIES. AB 1797 DESIGNATES
THE DUNGENESS CRAB AS
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL STATE
CRUSTACEAN TO HIGHLIGHT ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
VALUE, AND RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF SUSTAINABLE FISHING PRACTICES
AND MARINE CONSERVATION. THE
DUNGENESS CRAB HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL PART OF THE NORTH COAST
ECONOMY AND IDENTITY. IT'S VITAL
TO THE ECONOMY AND ECOSYSTEM
SYSTEMS IN COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN THE CALIFORNIA COAST, AND
FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. ANY LEAD WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT? IT'S JUST ME.
YOU'RE DOING THIS ALL ON YOUR
OWN SOLO. WOW. JUST LIKE CRABS.
VERY IMPRESSIVE. ONE AT A TIME,
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? YOU ARE
DOING THIS ALL ALONE? I AM.
WELL, WE'LL MOVE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. WELL, I JUST HAVE A
PRESSING QUESTION. ARE WE
PARTIAL TO CHESAPEAKE BAY
SEASONING OR GARLIC AND OIL
SEASONING? WHEN WE EAT OUR CRABS
, WE HAVE AN OPINION. I THINK
WE'RE PARTIAL TO GARLIC AND
BUTTER AND. OKAY. JUST CURIOUS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT. THIS IS THE
DUNGENESS CRAB. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SO THAT THEY CAN'T BE
HUNTED ANYMORE. NO NO. OKAY.
WELL, I JUST, I HAD ONE COMMENT,
PLEASE. WELL, ALTHOUGH A BUNCH
OF QUESTIONS COME TO MIND, I'M
REALLY ANXIOUS TO GET TO THE
SLUG, SO I'M GOING TO FOREGO MY
QUESTIONING. AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US THE CRUSTACEAN BILL.
SO I'LL GIVE YOU MY CLOSING
COMMENT BEFORE I LET YOU DO YOUR
CLOSING COMMENT. I'VE BEEN
PRETTY CRANKY ON THESE. YOU
KNOW, THESE, NAMING AS AS THE
CHAIR OF, THIS COMMITTEE OVER
THE LAST SIX YEARS OR SO. BUT I
SECOND THE CRANKINESS. I'VE LOST
THE, I'VE LOST MY WILL AND MY
WAY ON THIS. AND PARTICULARLY,
GOING TO SO MANY CRAB FEEDS OVER
THE YEARS, I'M PARTICULARLY
PARTIAL TO THIS ONE. SO YOU MAY
CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S JUST,
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I THINK
IT'S TIME TO CELEBRATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE DUNGENESS
CRAB. I'M. I KNOW NOW,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. YOU
HAD US. I'M A NO NOW. YOU HAD US
. NO. I KNEW IT WAS A STRETCH.
SO. SO SOMETIMES BREVITY IS
BETTER. ALL RIGHT. THANKS. WHEN
WE GET. I THINK WE SHOULD CLAW
BACK THAT ONE NOW. YEAH WELL,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND YOUR FORGIVENESS FOR MY
REALLY BAD JOKE. YOU GOT IT.
THIS ONE. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
1857 MEMBER PELLERIN. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD. IS IT SO.
MORNING. AFTERNOON. RIGHT. OH,
AFTERNOON. AFTERNOON OH MY GOSH.
TIME FLIES WHEN YOU'RE HAVING
FUN. MORNING. SOMEWHERE IT'S.
THANK YOU MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
, EXISTING STATE LAW AS YOU
KNOW, ESTABLISHES VARIOUS STATE
SYMBOLS, INCLUDING THE STATE
FLOWER, THE STATE BIRD AND THE
STATE TREE. AND HOPEFULLY
SOMEDAY, THE CRUSTACEAN. THESE
STATE SYMBOLS BRING ABOUT
HISTORICAL AND CULTURAL
APPRECIATION TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS LEARNING ABOUT
THEIR STATE AS WELL AS TO
VISITORS WHO LEARN ABOUT OUR
STATE SYMBOLS AND EDUCATIONAL
SPACES LIKE MUSEUMS AND OUR VERY
OWN STATE CAPITOL BUILDING.
TODAY, THERE IS NO STATE SLUG.
AND TO BOOST APPRECIATION FOR
THIS ICONIC SPECIMEN, AB 1850,
WHICH WAS NUMBERED AFTER THE
YEAR CALIFORNIA OFFICIALLY
BECAME A STATE RECOGNIZES THE
BANANA SLUG AS CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICIAL STATE SLUG. BANANA
SLUGS PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
MAINTAINING OUR STATE'S
ECOLOGICAL HEALTH. AS DETRIVORES
, AND ARE LARGELY ENDEMIC TO THE
STATE. CURRENTLY, THERE ARE AT
LEAST SIX SPECIES OF BANANA
SLUGS FOUND AND RECORDED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA, OF WHICH ONLY ONE
SPECIES, THE PACIFIC BANANA SLUG
, IS FOUND OUTSIDE THE STATE. IN
1986, THE UNIVERSITY OF SANTA
CRUZ ADOPTED THE BANANA SLUG AS
ITS OFFICIAL MASCOT, TO WHICH
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY CULTURAL
REFERENCES, INCLUDING A
SHOWCASING OF THE MASCOT IN THE
1994 MOVIE PULP FICTION. THIS
BILL SO FAR HAS FACILITATED
IMMENSE, LIGHTHEARTED CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. AS MY OFFICE
RECENTLY SPONSORED AN ART
CONTEST IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND RECEIVED SOME GORGEOUS
ARTISTIC RENDERINGS OF OUR
BELOVED SLUG. THE BANANA SLUG IS
SIMPLY A GREAT REPRESENTATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL COASTAL
CULTURE AND IS HIGHLY
IDENTIFIABLE. THIS BILL WILL
SIMPLY GIVE THE BANANA SLUG THE
RECOGNITION IT SO SORELY, SURELY
DESERVES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, GENE HEARST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
SUPPORT, OF COURSE, SANTA CRUZ.
ANYBODY ELSE? ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE SEN. PORTANTINO. SO
IN KEEPING WITH THE LEVITY OF
THE DAY, WHAT DO WE HAVE AGAINST
THE GRAY GARDEN SLUG, WHICH IS
THE MOST PLENTIFUL SLUG IN
CALIFORNIA? WELL THE BANANA SLUG
IS CERTAINLY ICONIC, AND IT HAS
THIS LARGEST SLUG. WELL, IT'S
LARGE IN SIZE, FOR SURE. AND
YOU'RE SPORTING THE BEAUTIFUL
YELLOW THAT THE BANANA SLUG
WEARS WHEN IT'S OUT AND ABOUT IN
THE REDWOOD FOREST, WITH ITS
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
REDWOOD FOREST. AND, AND DOES A
GREAT JOB TO ALSO EAT POISON OAK
, SO YOU DON'T WANT TO EVER KISS
A BANANA SLUG IN CASE IT JUST
RECENTLY HAD A MEAL OF POISON
OAK. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I'M
JUST GOING TO ASK IF THEY WERE
COOK ABLE, BUT NO, DEFINITELY
NOT. NOT APPARENTLY NOT. SO
WE'RE NOT TOLD THEM THEY'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE A RIVAL FOR THE
ESCARGOT GROUP. NEVER. NO NO, NO
BUTTER OR GARLIC WITH SLUGS.
EXCELLENT. OH, NO. ANYBODY ELSE?
NOT SEEING ANY. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? WELL, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. JOB SO FAR. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. I THINK THE BANANA
SLUG IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING VERY
ENDEARING TO MANY OF US. WE EVEN
HAD THIS FIRST GRADE CLASS THAT
THEY DID A WHOLE SERIES OF ART
AND REPORTS ON THE BANANA SLUG.
THERE'S LOTS TO LEARN AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE'RE GOING TO
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM HERE, WE
WILL, MOST CERTAINLY BE VOTING
ON YOU MAY HAVE IT AND WE MAY
HAVE IT. SO YOU CAN WAIT. OH,
WAIT A MINUTE. WE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD HERE. DODD HERE. WILK.
PRESENT WILK. PRESENT. ALVARADO.
GILL. ALVARADO. GILL. HERE
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA. HERE.
ASHBY. BRADFORD GLASER. JONES.
I'M HERE. JONES HERE. NGUYEN.
OKUBO. PADILLA PRESENT. PADILLA.
PRESENT. PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO.
HERE. ROTH HERE. ROTH. HERE.
RUBIO. CIARDO. HERE. CERRADO.
HERE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
FANTASTIC. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON AB 1850? MAKE A MOTION. WE'VE
GOT IT. ARCHULETA MOVES, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DODD. AYE DODD AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY BRADFORD. GLASER.
JONES AYE AYE. JONES. AYE
NGUYEN. OKUBO. PADILLA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH A ROTH. AYE. RUBIO.
CELADO. SERRATO AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. 78. BILL HAS EIGHT AND
ZERO NOES. WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE RIGHT NOW TO OUR, CONSENT
ITEMS. CAN WE GET A MOTION FOR
THAT, PLEASE? THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOTION TO MOVE
CONSENT. SO WE GOT MOVE BY
ARCHULETA. CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE
. DODD. I THINK I'M SUPPOSED TO
READ THESE AFTER ALL THIS. YES,
YOU ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE,
AB 1940, VILLA PADUA, FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, AB 1946 ATLANTIS
FILE. ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 2177
MCKINNEY FILE. ITEM NUMBER SIX
2232. MOONSHINE FILE NUMBER TEN,
AB 2682. HART FILE ITEM NUMBER
11, AB 3017 HART AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12 2849 RUBIO. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
DODD. YES, I DODD AYE. ALVARADO.
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. BRADFORD. GLASER JONES.
JONES. AYE. NGUYEN OKUBO.
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SALADO.
SERRATO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
BILL HAS NINE VOTES. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO, MOVE TO FILE NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 2359. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG,
YOU'VE BEEN PATIENT OVER THERE
WAITING AND HUMORED THE WHOLE
WAY. I'M SURE I WAS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT SOME SORT OF LINK TO
SAN FRANCISCO, BUT I'LL JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO THE BILL, AB 2359 IS
A DISTRICT BILL, PREVIOUS BILL,
WHICH THE COMMITTEE SUPPORTED,
GAVE TYPE 87 LIQUOR LICENSES FOR
30 AFFORDABLE LIQUOR LICENSES IN
SPECIFIC SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS. THIS BILL JUST
AMENDS THAT TO GO FROM 30 TO 40.
IT'S BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I VOTE FOR AB 2359.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BEN VAN
HOUTEN FROM THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO, SPONSOR OF THE
BILL, ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THE TYPE 87 LIQUOR
LICENSE HAS REALLY BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR RESTAURANT
VOIGTS IN OUR OUTER
NEIGHBORHOODS IN SAN FRANCISCO,
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW
RESTAURANTS AND NEIGHBORHOOD
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
STRENGTHENING EXISTING
RESTAURANTS. IT'S BEEN GREAT FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE'RE ASKING
FOR, TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THAT SUCCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE?
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. DILLON
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
? NONE. SEEING NONE, WE'LL TURN
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE
THE BILL. WE GOT A MOTION BY
ROTH. ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING? PERFECT. WE GOT A
MOTION BY ROTH. IT IS, JUST
FOSTER AND VOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LIKE A PRO.
LIKE A PRO. ALL RIGHT, SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD. AYE. DODD AYE. WILK AYE.
WILK AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
GLASER JONES. AYE. JONES. AYE.
NGUYEN OKUBO. PADILLA. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO CIERTO. CIERTO AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL NOW MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
2378 CALDERON ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS. I'D LIKE TO
OPEN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2378
WOULD EXEMPT APPROVED BARTENDING
OR MIXOLOGY APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FROM NEEDING AN ABC
LICENSE TO SERVE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES AS PART OF ITS
CURRICULUM. ABC LICENSES ARE NOT
INTENDED TO BE ISSUED TO
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS UNDER
CURRENT LAW. IT IS UNCLEAR IF
BARTENDING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR ABC
LICENSING, AND IF SO, WHICH KIND
OF LICENSE THEY WOULD NEED. THIS
LEGAL UNCERTAINTY HAS PREVENTED
BARTENDING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FROM OPERATING DESPITE
BEING APPROVED BY THE STATE.
FURTHERMORE WITHOUT AN ABC
LICENSE OR EXEMPTION,
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS CANNOT
UTILIZE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES IN
THEIR TRAINING. THE PRACTICE OF
TASTING IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THE LEARNING OF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THE FLAVORS, TEXTURES,
AND STRENGTHS OF THESE
BEVERAGES. AB THREE 2378 ENSURES
THAT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
HOSPITALITY WORKERS ARE FULLY
TRAINED AND EQUIPPED WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO ADVANCE
THEIR CAREERS. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE AARON
GREENBERG AND MITCHELL FRIEDER
OF THE HOSPITALITY TRAINING
ACADEMY. GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON? GOOD AFTERNOON. THIS
IS WORKING. YES, GREAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US. MY NAME IS AARON
GREENBERG. I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE HOSPITALITY
TRAINING ACADEMY. WE ARE A 500
AND 1C3 ORGANIZATION, AND WE'RE
THE TRAINING ARM OF THE
HOSPITALITY WORKERS UNION UNITE
HERE LOCAL 11 AND A PARTNERSHIP
WITH OVER 170 PARTNERS, EMPLOYER
PARTNERS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
EVERY YEAR WE TRAIN HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE TO BECOME ROOM
ATTENDANTS, PREP COOKS, LINE
COOKS AND BARISTAS AT SOME OF
THE LARGEST HOSPITALITY
EMPLOYERS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AT HOTELS, AIRPORTS, EVENT
CENTERS, STADIUMS ACROSS THE
REGION. WE WORK WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
WORKFORCE SYSTEM, INCLUDING THE
AJC'S, TO RECRUIT STUDENTS FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE, INCLUDING
JUSTICE INVOLVED AND REENTRY
VETERANS, FOSTER YOUTH, DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS, PEOPLE AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OUR
EMPLOYER PARTNERS KNOW US SO
WELL, AND THEY KNOW OUR
GRADUATES AND THE QUALITY OF THE
TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE.
EVERYONE WHO FINISHES OUR
PROGRAM GETS A JOB OFFER. THE
HIGH ROAD JOBS THAT THEY THEN
HAVE ACCESS TO PROVIDE A PATH TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS, GOOD WAGES,
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS, DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE UP THE
CAREER LADDER. WE'VE SPONSORED
AND CREATED FOUR REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND THE
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS, BUT TO
DATE, WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RUN OUR BARTENDER MIXOLOGIST
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. AS CHEF
MITCHELL WILL EXPLAIN IN JUST A
MINUTE. THIS IS A VERY
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM, AND IT COULD
OPEN UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
TO REALLY EXCELLENT CAREERS IN
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. THE
APPRENTICESHIP, LIKE THE OTHERS
THAT WE RUN, HAS BEEN BLESSED
AND REGISTERED BY THE US DOL AND
WITH DÍAS. YOU WOULDN'T WANT A
CHEF TO COOK FOOD THAT THEY
CAN'T TASTE. AND I'M TEMPTED TO
MAKE A DUNGENESS CRAB JOKE HERE.
BUT YOU ALSO DON'T WANT
BARTENDERS TO TRAIN WITHOUT
TASTING AND BEING ABLE TO, YOU
KNOW, UNDERSTAND A CORRECTLY
PORTIONED MARTINI OR THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN RUM AND RYE.
BUT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
FOR THAT KIND OF TASTING IN THE
COURSE OF A TRAINING PROGRAM
THAT WE RUN, BECAUSE WE'RE A
NONPROFIT AND NOT A 2 OR 4 YEAR
ACCREDITED EDUCATION
INSTITUTION, IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
OUR ACCESS TO AN ABC LICENSE IS.
AB 2378 WOULD ALLOW
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS LIKE
OURS. WE ARE THE ONLY ONE IN
EXISTENCE NOW, BUT WE HOPE THAT
THERE WILL BE MORE THAT WILL
FLOURISH, WILL ALLOW US TO ALLOW
BARTENDERS IN TRAINING ABOVE THE
AGE OF 21 TO TASTE ALCOHOL AS
PART OF THEIR TRAINING. IT'S A
SMALL CHANGE TO THE LAW. IT'S A
SMALL ADMINISTRATIVE FIX, BUT
CAN REALLY BE GAME CHANGING FOR
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
IN OUR REGION AND ACROSS THE
STATE TO GIVE ACCESS TO, TO
EXCELLENT JOBS IN THIS INDUSTRY.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. BEFORE WE
TALK ABOUT THIS, BILL, I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
BANANA SLUGS ARE INDEED EDIBLE
AND THE ONLY THING IS YOU HAVE
TO BE PURGED FIRST. YOU HAVE TO
KEEP THEM AROUND AND FEED THEM
LETTUCE TO PURGE THEIR SYSTEM.
AFTER WHICH YOU COULD EAT THEM.
BUT THEY'RE SO CUTE IT BECOMES
DIFFICULT. BUT THEY ARE VERY
TASTY. BOURGUIGNON OR IN SLUG
BUTTER. AWESOME. OKAY, SO NOW
THAT WE'VE CLARIFIED THAT, I
UNDERSTAND THEY TASTE LIKE
CHICKEN, THEY TASTE MORE LIKE
ESCARGOT. OKAY. YOU KNOW, BUT
AND THEY TEND TO LOSE THEIR
COLOR WHEN YOU COOK THEM. NOW
THAT WE'VE LOST TOTAL CONTROL.
OKAY. CONTINUE PLEASE. HAPPY
HAPPY TO BE PART OF THE LOSS OF
CONTROL, YEAH. SO THIS THIS BILL
IS THIS CHANGE IN THE BILL IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE BAR-TENDER'S UNDER STAND
THE PROCESS OF MAKING PROPER
DRINKS. AND WE OUR TRAINING
PROGRAM IS, IS A VERY, VERY
STRINGENT ONE THAT THAT TRAINS
TO A VERY, VERY HIGH LEVEL. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO TASTE THE BEVERAGES, THE
TASTES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
TAKEN WITH A STRAW LIKE THIS.
OKAY. SO IT'S PLACED IN A DRINK.
FINGERS PUT ON TOP. YOU END UP
WITH ABOUT WELL, IT IS A 16TH OF
A TEASPOON PER TASTE. SO 16
TASTES LIKE THIS WOULD EQUAL A
TEASPOON. WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
ANY STUDENT TASTING MORE THAN
ABOUT 20 MAX 30 TIMES DURING THE
COURSE OF A DAY. SO WE'RE
TALKING A COUPLE OF TEASPOONS OF
ALCOHOL THAT MIGHT BE CONSUMED,
BUT THEN WILL ALSO HAVE AN
UNSAVORY TERM. BUT SPIT BUCKETS
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO SPIT INTO
AND WILL ENCOURAGE THE STUDENTS
TO SPIT AS WELL. SO REALLY TINY
LITTLE BITS OF ALCOHOL WILL BE
CONSUMED. AND WE DON'T BRING
STUDENTS INTO OUR PROGRAM WHO
ARE UNDER THE AGE OF 21 ANYWAY.
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL SUPPORT
THIS CHANGE AND THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
EXCUSE ME. SORRY, ELMER. BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WITH ANY. OKAY.
I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION. OKAY.
WE'LL GO RIGHT DOWN THE LINE.
ARCH FLUTTER. YOU'RE UP. OKAY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THAT'S A IT'S A
GREAT BILL. I HAD NO IDEA THAT
THAT IT TOOK SO MUCH INSTRUCTION
AND A NUMBER OF MONTHS AND
MONTHS TO ACTUALLY BE A GOOD,
QUALIFIED, BARTENDER TO THIS
DEGREE. AND, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW
, WE ALWAYS WANT OUR STUDENTS TO
REACH THE TOP UPSCALE HOTELS AND
RESORTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE. AND
I GUESS THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
IS SO IMPORTANT, AND I CAN SEE
HOW VITAL THIS IS. I THINK IT'S
A GREAT BILL. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE IT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. BUT I CONGRATULATE
YOU FOR BRINGING IT ON, ON, ON
TO US. SO THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR JONES, THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN, CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE, PART OF THE BILL THAT IT'S
UNION ONLY AND WHY NOT OPEN IT
UP TO ALL KINDS OF
APPRENTICESHIPS AND MAYBE
INCLUDE IN YOUR ANSWER, WHY IS
AN APPRENTICESHIP EVEN
NECESSARY? DON'T MOST BARTENDERS
JUST LEARN ON THE JOB ANYWAYS? I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT MOST
BARTENDERS. I KNOW THAT I'M
GOING TO DEFER TO MY WITNESS.
THAT'D BE FINE. AND THEN IF YOU
CAN AFTER THAT ANSWER, IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THE WHY UNION
ONLY I'D APPRECIATE THAT I CAN I
CAN ADDRESS BOTH OF THOSE THINGS
ACTUALLY AS WELL. SO, THE UNION
ONLY PART OUR ORGANIZATION IS,
ALLIED WITH THE UNION. WE ARE
NOT THE UNION. WE'RE WE'RE
SWITZERLAND. WE DON'T TAKE
SIDES, BUT THE JOBS, THAT WE
THAT WE TRAIN FOR ARE VERY
HIGHLY PAID. AND THEY COME WITH,
WITH EXCELLENT BENEFITS FOR
WHICH THE EMPLOYEES PAY ZERO,
THEY PAY NO CO-PAYS, THEY DON'T
PAY FOR THE INSURANCE AT ALL.
THAT'S ALL INCLUDED. SO WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE LEADING OUR STUDENTS
INTO ARE REALLY CAREER JOBS, A
JOB THAT WILL SUPPORT THEM,
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY. AND THEY
HAVE TO PROTECTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE CONTINUING ON. IF
THEIR MANAGER, FOR SOME REASON
IS ANNOYED AT THEM, AND WITH OUR
POPULATION, THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AGAIN, WE'RE
DRAWING FROM POPULATIONS WHO ARE
WHO HAVE DIFFICULTY BREAKING
INTO THESE JOBS. THEY DON'T HAVE
THE BACKGROUND, THE FAMILY
BACKGROUNDS TO, TO, TO LEAD THEM
TO FIND THESE JOBS AND GET
TRAINED FOR THEM OR TO PAY FOR
THE TRAINING. SO THAT'S THE
FIRST PART OF IT. MANY
BAR-TENDER'S WELL, THERE ARE
SOME BAR-TENDER'S LEARN ON THE
JOB. THEY START AS BAR BACKS.
THEY WERE FETCHING ICE. THEY
WERE CLEANING THINGS LIKE THIS,
THOSE JOBS DO NOT PAY AS WELL.
SO OUR TRAINING PROGRAM, AS WITH
OUR CULINARY PROGRAM AND OUR
OTHER APPRENTICESHIPS, TRAINED
TO AN EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH LEVEL
SO THEY CAN STEP IN. AT LEAST
THE TOP END OF THE CLASS, IN
PARTICULAR, CAN STEP IN. AND AS
A BARTENDER, INITIALLY, THEY'LL
BE FRIGHTENED, BUT THEY CAN DO
THE JOB. SO IT GIVES THEM A STEP
UP AND MOVING AHEAD. AND WE HAVE
OUR OUR EMPLOYER PARTNERS WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM WHO SUPPORT THE
MISSION, SUPPORT THE GOAL AND
SPEND TIME TRAINING THESE
PEOPLE. WHEREAS IN OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS, PERHAPS THEY
DON'T. THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
PEOPLE WITH ONLY WITH EXPERIENCE
AND WE'RE ABLE TO GET PEOPLE IN
THE DOOR. IN A MORE EFFECTIVE
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE HAVE A
QUESTION? I'M GOING TO EXPAND ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT. I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED. SO THEY GO INTO THE
CLASS AND YOUR CLASS IS NEUTRAL.
AND THEN THEY CAN GO INTO A
UNION JOB OR THEY CAN NOT GO
INTO A UNION JOB. THEY CAN BE
HIRED BY ANYBODY. LISTEN, THEY
HAVE VERY WELL. YEAH. THAT'S
WHAT I'M THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT. WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO GO
INTO A JOB WHERE THEY CAN
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY AND HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THE, OF THE
BENEFITS, AND WE'RE NOT AGAINST
ANY OF THAT. I'M JUST SAYING THE
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM IS ANYBODY
Þ? SURE. AND LISTEN, WE GO TO
GET TO DO WHAT THEY WANT. WE
PLACE PEOPLE WITH THEIR
BACKGROUND ISSUES IN IN NONUNION
JOBS AS WELL, UNTIL THEIR
BACKGROUND IS CLEAR ENOUGH THAT
WE COULD PUT THEM IN A IN A JOB
THAT'S PERHAPS PAYS BETTER. YEAH
IT MAY BE WORTH SAYING A BIT
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF OUR
ORGANIZATION. WE'RE A LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP. SO A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE UNION
AND UNITE HERE LOCAL 11 AND
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS. OUR
BOARD IS 50% UNION, 50%
EMPLOYERS. THE GOAL OF THE
ORGANIZATION OVERALL IS TO TRAIN
NEW WORKERS AND UPSKILL CURRENT
WORKERS WHO WORK AT THOSE
EMPLOYERS. BUT AS CHEF MITCHELL
SAID, WHILE WE CAN ENSURE THAT
AT THE END OF THE PROGRAM A
GRADUATE WILL HAVE A JOB OFFER,
IT'S UP TO THEM WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO TAKE IT OR NOT OR GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. BUT THE GOAL OF
THE ORGANIZATION IS REALLY TO BE
THE TRAINING ARM OF THE UNION
AND ITS CONTRIBUTING EMPLOYERS,
WHICH INCLUDE DISNEY, HILTON,
MARRIOTT, MOST OF THE MAJOR,
LEVI COMPASS GROUP FOOD SERVICE,
MOST OF THE MAJOR EMPLOYERS IN
HOSPITALITY IN OUR REGION. FINE.
THANK YOU. YEAH MY POINT OUT
THAT THERE WAS A BILL. I THINK
IT WAS MY BILL. I'M NOT
MISTAKEN, BEFORE COVID THAT WE
HAD, WHICH, ALLOWED HOSPITALITY
PROGRAMS AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, STATE UNIVERSITIES AND
UCS TO DO THE SAME EXACT THING.
SO THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS.
ANYBODY ELSE? I JUST WANTED TO
ADD, MR. CHAIR, YOU KNOW, AND
I'M APPRECIATING THE
PRESENTATION AND THE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WHAT I
APPRECIATE ABOUT APPRENTICESHIP
IS THAT IT'S CAREER DRIVEN, IN
MY DISTRICT, AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE
AN ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL. AND
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
IN HIGH END, HIGH ROAD
HOSPITALITY JOBS THAT, YOU KNOW,
FROM INDEPENDENT HOTELS TO
ENTERTAINMENT CENTERS TO
CONVENTION CENTERS AND WHAT I
APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT SOMEONE CAN COME IN AS A
BARISTA BUT GET TRAINED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE UP THAT CAREER
LADDER. AND SO, YOU KNOW, THIS
PROGRAM IS VERY IMPORTANT. YOU
KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT WE HAD
TO GET THIS KIND OF POLICY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TRAINING
PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THESE ARE CAREERS, NOT JOBS, BUT
CAREERS THAT FOLKS CAN MOVE UP
AND PROVIDE THE WORKFORCE THAT
WE NEED IN A PLACE LIKE LA
COUNTY. SO THANK YOU. PERFECT
THANKS. OKAY, ANYBODY ELSE
SEEING NONE. WE. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SORRY, SENATOR ARCHULETA, BUT
SENATOR PADILLA GOT THERE BEFORE
YOU, THAT'S ON AB 2378. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS IS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD. AYE. DODD AYE. WILK AYE.
WILK AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
BRADFORD GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
JONES NGUYEN. OKUBO. PADILLA A.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. SATO A SERRANO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE WEN NGUYEN. AYE
THANK YOU. 11. IT HAS 11 VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MEMBER. DIXON
WE'VE GOT A SEASHELL. SENATOR
WINSTON, TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
. THE WIND IS GOING TO BE. IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SENATOR
NGUYEN IS GOING TO PRESENT, FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 2504 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS, I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 20 504 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIANNE DIXON. AB
2504 WILL RECOGNIZE THE BLACK
ABALONE AS THE OFFICIAL STATE
SEASHELL OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A
BEAUTIFUL, VAST COASTLINE AND A
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOT. IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
PRESERVATION OF OUR ECOSYSTEM
THAT WE RECOGNIZE KEY FEATURES
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA SO SPECIAL.
THE BLACK ABALONE IS UNIQUE TO
THE ROCKY ZONES OF CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO. THE SHELL OF THE
BLACK ABALONE HAS GREAT
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE AND WAS
USED BY NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
FOR FOOD, TRADE, JEWELRY, AND
EVEN ROYAL CEREMONY. IN THE 80S,
THE SHELL WAS ALMOST COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED FROM OUR SHORES
BECAUSE OF A FATAL DISEASE OF
THE ABALONE DIGESTIVE ORGANS IN.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AFTER AN
EL NINO EVENT. SINCE THEN, THE
BLACK ABALONE HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED AN ENDANGERED SPECIES
. I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE TO BRING
RECOGNITION TO THE BLACK ABALONE
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO YOU. THE
COMMITTEE. I'M JUST WONDERING IF
ABALONE EAT SLUGS. MOVE THE BILL
ONLY ON TUESDAY. SENATOR ROTH
MOVES. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON AB 2504.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH.
THE MOTION IS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TALK, SENATOR JONES IS TALKING.
I'M JUST I CAN'T STOP. NO, SIR.
OKAY. I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE, THE MOTION IS Dð. PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DODD. AYE. DODD.
AYE WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. HI
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
GLASER GLASER. AYE. JONES AYE.
JONES. AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE.
OCHOA. B¢O. PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. SALADO.
SIERRA. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE NINE
1011. IT HAS 11 VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN. SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO. THAT'S. YEAH. SO THAT
BILL THAT BILL IS OUT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO START ON THESE, WE'RE
GOING TO GO MOVE TO THE CONSENT
ITEMS. I'VE ALREADY LISTED ALL
THE CONSENT ITEMS. SO, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY BRADFORD GLASER. BLAZER.
AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA.
B¢O RUBIO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. THE
LAST 12. NINE. 12. SO WE'LL KEEP
THAT ON CALL. COULD WE HAVE, SO
WE HAVE. THAT'S IT. NO, NO, BUT
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS I WANT TO
MAKE A CALL TO THESE MEMBERS
THAT AREN'T HERE BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO KEEP THIS MEETING OPEN.
YEAH, OKAY. NO ONE ELSE IS
COMING. THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL
THING. OKAY. NUMBER ONE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE, FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. WILK
MOVES. SO WILK MOVES FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB 1797. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE FLOOR. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. BRADFORD. GLASER
GLASER. AYE. JONES. AYE. JONES.
AYE. NGUYEN NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA.
B¢O. PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. I'LL GET YOU A HÌNH.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO SALADO. HIGH SIERRA. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE I DID I DID HAVE
ENOUGH DEFEATING 11 GOOD
ANYMORE. TEN. 1111 THAT BILLS
OUT MOVED TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB 1850. PELLERIN WE HAVE
EIGHT EYES AND ZERO NOSE. WE'LL
OPEN THE ROLL, PLEASE. ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. ASHBY.
BRADFORD GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
NGUYEN. NGUYEN AYE. OCHOA. B¢O.
RUBIO. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE GILL HAS
11 NINE. 11. THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB 2359.
TING IT HAS TEN VOTES. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY. BRADFORD. GLASER. GLASER
AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE. OCHOA.
B¢O RUBIO. 12 GLASS. 12. THAT
BILL IS OUT. NUMBER EIGHT AB
2378 CALDERON, THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY. BRADFORD.
JONES OKUBO. RUBIO 1111 VOTES.
11. THAT BILLS OUT. I'M SORRY.
FILE NUMBER FIVE. IF YOU'RE ON
THERE. IT WAS ON THE CONSENT
ITEMS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
2504. DIXON IS EVERYBODY'S DONE
IT. WE CLOSE IT OUT. THAT
COMPLETES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY. AND YOU
LEFT. YOU NEVER PUT THOSE
CONSENT NUMBER OUT. YEAH WE DID.
YEAH WE DID. DID YOU. YEAH.
YEAH. OKAY THIS MEETING, AS
FUNNY AS IT WAS, IS ADJOURNED
THANKS TO THE STAFF EVERYBODY.
GREAT WORK. SNAILS AND SHELLS.